ukg is a leading provider of hr talent
workforce management and payroll
solutions
and our focus is absolutely on people in
fact our tagline which is much more than
a tagline is that our purpose is people
so when we think about some of the major
challenges that our organization faced
and just like our customers are facing
is that the reality is that the rules of
work are being rewritten and we wanted
to be part of rewriting those rules of
work rather than just reacting to what's
happening um in in in with so much
uncertainty so again this need to be um
to be incredibly adaptive led us to uh
to really wanting to take this devops
approach how do we implement lifework
technology internally as well as for our
customers one of the things that we
recognized is that we had to be hyper
hyper aware of whether or not
individuals were nearing burnout for
example what is it that we could do to
understand the makeup and the cohesion
of teams to ensure that we had
consistent output and throughput without
over taxing individuals whenever you see
a challenge or whenever we certainly at
ukg sees a challenge we think about it
in terms of
what is the person approach what how is
that impacting people
individually
and as a whole or teams and so we see
opportunities to actually bring new
products
to the market based on what our
experiences are we took the approach of
really adopting some cloud-native
attributes and capability that would
actually support kind of decoupling our
releases from the development life cycle
so that we could accelerate and bring
more value to our customers we have a
significant amount of cloud storage but
the most important um benefit that we
found with our deployment in particular
of using some of the cloud native
capabilities that gcp offered us to
change our delivery reduce
downtime significantly and also add
resilience to our overall delivery so
being able to do continuous integration
continuous delivery taking advantage of
some of the the metrics that came as
well as deploying
in one of our platforms we actually have
deployed the entire suite of google
analytics and embedded those directly
and so that we can see where usage is
happening the google team was incredible
in understanding how important those
three principles were to our teams so we
were able to get at in particular i want
to call out the
the ai and the machine learning team
because we got so much from our
collaboration
with that team as well as um across the
board the the the leadership the partner
team the partner organization in really
shaping
how we could take advantage of some of
those capabilities
you